dans la vigne rien ne les distingue des
autres saisonniers
pourtant ce soir cinq de ces vendangeurs
ne rentreront pas chez eux mais
retourneront à la maison d'arrêt de
blois
c'est le cas de tanguy qui purge une
peine de 18 mois pour violences et
d'arthur condamné à neuf mois de prison
pour des délits routiers
ban est dehors c'est un peu comme
liberté que cuba on nous fait confiance
à trois stars charme on profite de ça
pour pu pomper à la cellule quoi on
pense qu au présent mais on y va on sait
pourquoi on est là on sait ce qu'on a
fait est plus volatil et là de faire les
vendanges c'est un petit plus qui fait
de pouvoir faire un aménagement de peine
et de sortir plus si ça peut nous
permettre pas pour les autres
saisonniers
la présence de ses collègues
inhabituelle est l'occasion de se
débarrasser de quelques préjugés
je pense que c'est bien du coup d'être
au contact de ces gens là pour justement
déconstruire tout cette image générale
ac comme nourine bas de films américains
ou d'autres choses avec beaucoup de
violence du grand banditisme en fait ne
fait pas des ces gens là que j'ai vu ici
quand on a proposé à ce viticulteur
d'employer des détenus il n'a pas hésité
et même très satisfait de cette première
expérience
une vraie motivation qui est hyper
agréable pour quelqu'un qui a besoin de
saisonniers de gens qui connaissent pas
forcément le boulot et qui on a besoin
qu'ils soient qu'ils s'adaptent et avec
eux ça a été vraiment super pour ça ne
veut pas dire que c'est la meilleure
équipe de vendangeurs
depuis dix ans mais ils font partie des
meilleures équipes que j'ai en
semi-liberté ou bénéficiant de
permission de sortie les détenus sont
tous volontaires et rémunérés comme les
autres vendangeurs l'argent gagné va
leur permettre d'indemniser les parties
civiles mais aussi d'épargner pour leur
libération
il ya la sanction mais notre notre
première tâche à nous c'est aussi
d'éviter à ce que les gens reviennent en
prison et pour leur donner le goût de
parvenir en prison c'est justement leur
donner des outils pour se réinsérer à
l'extérieur déjà prometteuse
l'expérience pourrait bien être
renouvelée dès l'année prochaine